time you i drive down rampart here and
start across from tivoli village it's
huge and i've always wanted to come here
now i'm finally live here and we're
going to bring in mike thomas who is
with halloweentown a pumpkin patch and
you know i've been i've lived here quite
some time and i see it every year but
this has been around 20 years is that
correct yes throughout different
locations throughout the city we've been
here for 20 years that's unbelievable
why do you think it does so well every
year and it's just never gone away
halloween is everybody's holiday young
old everybody there's there's a costume
and a food an event for everybody
that is absolutely right and now now
we're talking about food
one thing you have to get down here
obviously is you could smell the food so
what do we eat here because i see a huge
amount of powdered sugar we have a
signature man would we haul that in from
like utah or something those are funnel
fries they're absolutely awesome these
are fun i know funnel cake what are the
funnel fries you ready to try a few
let's do it
let's roll it uh with everything on it
like like throw don't even hold back
just just you know just go hey
he looks like he needs like a thousand
pounds
right now oh my god it looks like it's
snowing it's snowing
i love it
so who came up with this concept you
know we had funnel cakes for a while and
then we loved it and then our chef just
out of nowhere came up with these funnel
fries
and we can't keep them in stock i bet
more strawberries more
more absolutely
oh man i swear it
okay yeah i'm gonna get but this time
this time of the year you should hold
back
no listen tonight we eat tomorrow the
diet okay gotcha all right i'm gonna try
one of these right because i gotta get
to where i'm gonna try one of these all
right here we go here we go
oh
fantastic kirsten christian meet me down
here i got funnel fries on me all right
here's your forecast okay
i have to eat and now do the forecast
what was i thinking all right here we go
temperatures
outside tonight are going to be mild all
right we're talking low 60s get out
there and enjoy clear nice tomorrow 84
degrees mostly sunny and warm i say warm
because it feels warm right now and
tomorrow will be warmer normal 75
degrees almost 10 degrees above average
winds a light breeze for tomorrow but if
you go to your eight day forecast you'll
notice on sunday we do have stronger
winds no need for a wind advisory
temperatures will drop a little to the
low 80s and then next week for the first
week of november can you believe it
first week of november already here mid
70s and right near average and i have an
additional graphic jason skip ahead here
we'll show you the forecast for tonight
or for halloween as all our monsters are
dancing temperatures are going to be
nice and mild there will be that breeze
but otherwise looking good back live now
oh you have the you guys out of the
listen i'm going to my my forecast is is
clear and yummy let's look at this oh
right let's do it together all right
mike
i only do this with people i love mike
just so you know what food do you like
yeah
oh
bellissima
back to you
i like the addition of the chocolate
sauce on top that's a good addition and
i know that you're shy but you would
tell me that you want to try some of
that right the strawberries weird meow
but everything else looks pretty good